Wow humility week to know every year
every year man you get hopped up on week
one you get real cocky we too come with
a bunch you last year week to a lot of
divisional games yes got a little
excited for week one
I got show how was your weekend it was
good it was busy but good I'm gonna
admit it's a little weird still not
having watched us a Sunday with you I
know so I watch I've been watching here
at the office I've learned all of the
TVs I set them up myself good for you ah
the mush Josh vendrick came and joined
me this weekend and he's the reason I
had such a bad day when in doubt blame
Josh Josh yes sort of fans do too
yes you watch over at NBC I did the one
o'clock game right near your house yes
but we did get to talk about this last
week yeah so I've washed with you right
you're the kind of guy where if you're
looking at it at a play and let's say a
pick six you're like oh [ __ ] come on are
you curse all that stuff yeah and you're
watching now with Tirico and Ronny
Harrison and Tony Dungy yes and
apparently Tony's not a cursor no Tony
doesn't curse people are scared to curse
in front of Tony always have heard this
throughout his career yeah how did you
hear that oh gosh
I think problems I had never heard the
first time yeah the first time I think I
ever heard it was probably my dad when
he was covering the cults like way back
when like you know he's he's a Christian
man he's doesn't believe in that kind of
talk and I can't be stopped no
guttural reacts yes when you're watching
football right you're gonna call out the
play you're gonna get upset that they've
already used that formation too many
times I don't go too crazy with that
stuff they're kind of professional
setting well I'm not not that it's you
know I don't mean that but I have some
elders I have to respect more so I guess
that's what it is and I mean Mike Tirico
is the Godfather he's in the room so I
always got to respect him but yeah Tony
Tony it's a great group nobody is to
ladder boisterous certainly some guys
here
you know oh is that whatever okay and
yes I will give me an example that
happened a week - um gosh well that
comes to my first one that comes to mind
I mean first thing is I sang my mo Aaron
Rodgers song at one point why we're all
watching and they all they love that
which is this hilarious so like he made
he made a throw or like he rolled out a
diagram and the Vikings not cometh to
beat you and they all started laughing
but then say well what was Mike I had
one cursing moment and I can't remember
what the what game was it might have
been like Pittsburgh yelling at their
demons like like the second time they
lit up the seam route for a touchdown I
was like what the [ __ ] are you doing
Pittsburgh are you seriously think
you're gonna [ __ ] cover that like
that and as soon as I get done I go
sorry coach and then everybody like
erupts in laughter because I everybody
knows me there yeah coach and Rodney are
still getting to know me I gotcha
and you think Dungey is he growing to
like you I think he is he actually
seemed like he was disappointed I was
leaving yesterday I thought you mean
what'd he say he's like all elite you're
leaving again huh quitting again on a
Sunday afternoon I was like yep I'm out
of here coach real Vontae Davis got a
pretty good show for you pals
so as we always do itec Sims late night
on the three stories that I want him to
dive into the film for Monday morning
things that I need explaining yeah
things that Sims is gonna explain today
Blake bortles doo-doo-doo
Patrick mahomes doo-doo-doo and darshan
Watson it's not it's more like - Shawn
what's this John Watson um is that Randy
Watson is that Randy uh so we have a lot
of stores are gonna do we're gonna get
to a little Eagles little Fitzpatrick
you're pointing a finger at me what is
it what are the bets end up though I'd
like a recap not the recap and when you
do well but damn it goes so bad at all
it's a bad weekend moving on there was
themes from Sunday well so do you know
where I am I am so I haven't really
added him up because I was in a fit of
rage last night and I was too busy
cursing out Josh for being my
I'm pretty sure that you went something
like five or six and ten right like I
think you're in that range we'll see
what happens tonight right I'm in the
211 and one range but you lied your big
game I think you're in the I have to do
the money I'm pretty sure you're at like
minus five or six hundred I think I'm in
the minus fifteen hundred and eighty yes
like like did you hear what I just said
bit minus fifteen hundred and eighty out
of a total of sixteen hundred so my
whole $900 leave right come I think
we're even I just say I surely hope so
it was a weird week that's why I took
your I couldn't believe you'd and I came
a deviated from what you do I know well
it just shows you like that's how I am
with everything got a diet do it for a
week everybody I looked at I was like
scary I know I got super cocky Broncos
yes sure they can cover six huh thanks a
lot Kyle with a blow that lead you
really cost me a lot how dare you so
we're gonna get into all that another
little note here and more birdies
Superbowl in Atlanta might have a bunch
of stuff going on that we think so might
want to get those tickets real quick you
don't even got to go to the game just
hang out Wednesday Thursday Friday your
dick gets hang out Sims left go gonna
talk to a lot of really cool athletes
right in front of your face yeah gonna
take over a bar just little birdies
little birdie birdies had a few people
reach out and said hey I got an air B&B
if you and Sims want to crash chirp
chirp chirp chirp chirp hey little
birdie
yeah just something I'm hearing by the
way we only needed like 15 points from
Odell last night and we didn't oh my
gosh well fantasy team lost Odell Rogers
I mean do we want to get into that right
off no no no lis crap unlike NBC we're
not gonna make giant scowl boys our top
story I'm a little tired of them early
on ever every gay in the last few years
is Giants cowboys we have to and it's
like 13 6 yeah I know they're not the
most exciting games that was pretty
pitiful display of offense there and who
I mean hey the pass protection wasn't
good but damn you lie Manning's not good
either I don't know what else to say
gonna get to that for sure okay just to
show you how crazy
it is the first two weeks I love these
there are seven undefeated teams after
two weeks a few of them make sense a few
of them you couldn't have got me to pick
this at all yeah the LA Rams of course
the Jacksonville Jaguars we said they
could go to and oh yeah so they can go
and to write our Miami Dolphins to a No
yes what one of my better bets that I
made it at the Borgata Cincinnati
Bengals are to a No taking down the
Colts and the Ravens impressed with them
on Thursday night they got athletes they
do Kansas City - and oh and they are
looking dead looking good I wouldn't
have guessed that one what I said it all
no way same division the Denver Broncos
- a no home-field advantage is sweet
Case Keenum I don't know if he's that up
or that down but he's all over the place
well he's aggressive that's the one
thing I do know he's not afraid to make
big throws and he makes some mistakes
doing that but it keeps the pressure on
you other - no team the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers it man it's Patrick man those
teams were a combined 54 and 58 last
year now 25 teams over the last three
years have started the season - and oh
yeah love the 25 14 made the playoffs 11
did not and only four of the 11 that did
not finished with losing record so if
you started off - and oh you didn't have
a losing record now last year there were
two teams that did that Denver and
Oakland so we'll see if Denver goes back
to back of having losing seasons are
starting to it out I'd be shocked other
signs of surprises can you name the top
five rushers in the NFL right now
oh it would take some guesses Phillip
Lindsey's Phillip Lindsey number 3 ding
ding ding it's cream hon up there no
he's not ok hold on I got fun to play at
home I'm pulling up my team's I haven't
Alvin Coleman in there haven't Coleman
it's not he's not okay hold on still
pulling up my team's what about our
man's game to play at home what about
our man Gordon and Sant Chargers he is
not okay short field didn't get the
yardage - hold on hold on let me see who
my Todd Gurley is not I'm gonna give it
to you numbers I didn't do
crap yesterday he had three touchdowns
nine yards right number five James
Conner Oh number four duh Lamar Miller
number three
Philip Lindsey number two Joe Mixon gosh
Daniel number one number one rusher in
the NFL for two games Matt Breda Breda
Breda yeah because the big Philip
Lindsey who Sims I believe was the first
person to really alert you to his
possibilities is also the first
undrafted free agent in NFL history with
more than a hundred yards from scrimmage
in his first two NFL game Wow
special he's made for the modern-day NFL
again that's all you know you said
before we started I can't think of who
he reminds me of he said he's like Alvin
Kamara yeah I don't I don't exactly I
know you mean you just got that that
twitch he does he's got that twitch he's
probably more straightaway explosive
than even Calvin Kamara I don't know if
he's quite as elusive side to side but
as we're seeing these guys throughout
the NFL they're dangerous I mean oh ok
get on the edge in the run game first
down get out you know outside of the
pass game make one guy miss touchdown
yeah he is acceleration zero to top
speed is also charts and I mean he's so
fast that when Royce Freeman comes in he
looks too slow I know I know who else
did you say on there oh the thing that's
amazing to me - I mean rushing is down
ok and passing is like through the roof
witches make sense because Oh lineman or
with the lack of contact are still
trying to figure crap out they're not as
physical and as far along as the
defensive line and we've got what 700
yard rushers to the first two weeks I
think that's pretty amazing we've also
had more like almost as many 400 yards
pastures in the first two weeks as like
the whole year life is everybody happy
and fantasy world Oh
points are up they are except if you had
a kicker that was one of the 19 missed
kicks yesterday including Zane Gonzalez
who missed four was cut afterwards
immediately if you think about the
Browns could be two and oh yeah if that
dude can make it if my aunt had balls
she'd be my uncle but possibly right
what uh as a player uncle aunt Wendy
a player with a kicker that misses a
kick like the Vikings cut their guy -
yeah are you just looking at them like
how does the team even like disgusted
they get ignored by just about everybody
when they don't know I mean they're
ignored they were like semi ignored but
still part of the group like yeah they
might have felt like some I have an
outsider but people would like joke
around with them that when you have
performances like those two yesterday no
one can look at you on the plane you're
not gonna be talked to and what's even
worse is the coaches I mean the head
coaches you know again they're sitting
there going man you're you're you're
[ __ ] up my life I'm gonna get fired
you Jackson sitting there going I turn
this around we had hard knocks yeah I
could be to a no having beaten the
Steelers the Saints and you've missed
two kicks inside 35 yes exactly right so
like 35 it's when you have only one job
and I will say hey there's pressure to
that job but I mean come on some of
those field goals and extra points that
they missed I don't like it it's
unbelievable
19 total missed kicks yesterday yeah
extra points everybody has to see it go
through and that's what I just think
we've seen so far in the last two years
ever since this rule change really is
that kickers are a little mental more
mentally weak than I think we thought
the Vikings went and signed Dan Bailey
and he was waiting to see which team
that was an actual contender yes was
gonna have an opening he was the winner
I think of week two and as everybody was
missing he became the winner of week two
yes I am NOT a winner I went oh and four
of my locks I cannot believe that the
Texans lost to a Titans team without
three tackles and their starting
quarterback couldn't believe it and I
think a lot of people your mentions were
the other loser you are so connected to
Blake bortles that when he plays like he
did yesterday right
everyone's going what are you gonna do
now it's one game in five years he
proved you wrong holy cow you're wrong
it's been 60 it's 66 game
and he proved you wrong finally it's
very funny it just shows you the power
of our podcast yeah everyone listens you
of it
it's okay bring it on I get it so a few
a few little notes about it before we
dive into you I want to get right into
your notebook yeah first thing if you
saw the keel in coal catch and you saw
the Dede Westbrook play and run after
catch then all of those hot takes in the
off season about how their wide
receivers were trash they're not trash
if somebody told you that Jacksonville's
wide receivers are trash trash I don't
care what neck network it is whatever it
is that they you really should stop
listening cuz then did they're really
not watching football
hit the unfollow I mean Dede Westbrook
was a first-round pick at wide receiver
except he had a ton of off the field
issues
I mean DJ charkh okay here's another guy
I would have put him in there in the
Calvin Ridley GJ more conversation I
know that's where the Jacksonville
Jaguars had him yeah but cute little
vessel right that's all right just
because it didn't come from a Michigan
or Ohio State nobody can wrap their wrap
their head around it you know let alone
Austin severe Ian Jenkins and then Niles
Paul to go along with it and that great
kid the running back ran is special er
to the backfield so again I'm not trying
to take away from Blake bortles there
but no that's they are legit oh oh and
that's right Donte Moncrief who just
goes up and beast people four touchdowns
to was unbelievable yeah great athletes
they are alright let's get into Sims as
notes about bortles O'Carroll self
scouting right here I want to know how
he made it happen and Sims it's always
so gracious I'm gonna stay with the
bordel stuff first
right and then we'll get into more
Jacksonville offense and then more Oh
Patriots defense yeah because it could
be a serious uh right first thing your
own not the first thing bortles never
throws spirals but at least they're on
target yes kind of a backhanded
compliment yes I mean it's never it
never comes out of his hand clean very
rarely but you know it's better than
throwing wobblers that were uncatchable
which is what we've seen a lot of so the
one thing I've seen a little over here
the first two weeks and last week was
solid but not great at least work
in the ballpark just about every throw
to where I go okay okay the receivers
got a chance oh okay
hit the receiver in the numbers gave him
a chance to run with the ball after the
catch
those are big time things and he's
gotten really good at crossers and fades
that's right yes sir they don't they
don't make the formula simp mean
complicated that's really what they do
it's screens its fades wheel route its
wheel routes which it really ends up
being fades yes the same thing you know
what I mean it's the same thing and then
it is it's crosses over the middle I
mean like to play he threw the
interception on that was about the
fourth play they'd gone to that play
they go to that play three to four times
a game it's in one of their will they
pick two guys coming across if somehow
you cover them he throws to the tight
end who's like 12 yards right over the
middle well New England on that play
switched it up and passed off crossers
to where the guy fell off underneath
because they had seen the play a few
times and they were expecting it you
also wrote here's a good compliment you
bortles as tough as hell he really is I
again I know man
I mean bortles he's gonna hate me
forever and maybe he beats my ass when I
see him in person I'm not gonna just let
him beat my ass just so you know but yes
I mean he plays the game fearless and
that's what I do really respect about
him not only just like running and
lowering his head and hitting Stephon
Gilmore like that was a big time
collision doing stuff like that but you
know standing in there and not worrying
about oh okay they're crossing routes
open I'm gonna get hit screw it I'm
gonna throw it hey there was a
quarterback I watched last night on
Sunday Night Football it's not willing
to do that number 10 for the Giants if
you're wondering who that is
so yes I mean I bet there's credit to
that there is value in that and it keeps
the ball it keeps him from getting
sacked it keeps them in manageable
situations and yeah he gives his
receivers a chance to okay I'm getting
hit let me give you a chance that maybe
go get the ball really most of your
notes about the Jaguars offense are
about the strength of the o-line oh what
it lets them do oh so let me just ask
you to quickly summarize in your own
word right you know what did we watch at
bortles yesterday we watched in bortles
yesterday the greatest game he's played
in his career I mean he was on point
decision-making you know throw
were for the most part all pretty much
on point gave receivers a chance it
wasn't like wild car game Sunday last
year gets Buffalo you're like damn I
mean Michael Jordan could have couldn't
have you know done jumped up and touch
that ball LeBron James couldn't even
touched it so he's managing the position
the right way he's making decisions and
going with it and being confident with
it and like I said he's the plays that
are there to be had he is taking
advantage of them and that has not been
something he's going to do and if that
continues like I've said to you earlier
before we started a chalk it up they're
gonna win the Superbowl they're the best
team in football and if he can just hit
those plays somewhat consistently that
are there to be delivered big they're
durham they're tough to be stopped
because of the weapons outside we know
the defense the o-line is just an
absolute hulking beast I mean I believe
I wrote in there at one point like
sometimes there's no holes you're runnin
he wrote even in run place with no hole
they mash the defensive line back and
still gained 44 yards I mean it's like
damn there's really not a hole but
everybody's been blown off the line of
scrimmage to where TJ Yeldon just kind
of ducks his head and gets behind Andrew
Norwell and he falls to the ground and
it's second and six yeah so it is
phenomenal what they do but yes it's cut
you said this been the preseason it's
kind of like an unstoppable offense it
because they hit you at every level they
hit you at every level and then when you
think you got them covered and you go oh
we got a stopped here a bortles running
ability adds another element to it and
he made a few runs during the game
yesterday where yeah they were big like
you thought oh okay
New England might be getting ahold of
this offense here oh damn
you can't you can't leave that rushing
lane open with him he's gonna run for
ten yards and get a first down I feel
like you have something to say to
bortles
other than I'm sorry oh I do have
something to say other than I'm sorry um
I mean I feel like I'm part of this
Blake bortles
I feel like I brought you to this moment
I feel like I do I deserve some credit
everybody else was just telling you how
good of a guy
you were in the locker room how nice of
a guy you are he's great leader oh we
like five he's awesome he's good no one
wanted to say no really you're the
downfall of the team and you stink like
I did and I feel like damn I'm just
about ever since I've said that it's
gotten a whole lot better not instantly
but the playoffs we saw a step forward
now we've seen another step forward here
through two weeks uh and yeah that's
what I'm saying maybe he needed that
enemy or that [ __ ] like myself to
push him over the edge and we know that
he's bothered by it he's admitted that I
am the one person that has bothered him
in this conversation so you are the
motivation
I'm the motivation sometimes you need to
motivate I mean maybe he's maybe when he
drops back to throw in the offseason he
has dummies with my face on him and he's
[ __ ] breaking my face maybe he
doesn't know but now he had motivation
like that guy's a jerk-off I'm gonna
throw lasers and hit the target and he's
he's so you're really saying you're
welcome I'm sure I am saying you're
welcome bike you needed this extra push
over the edge and I I supplied it for
you there you go I always say that a a
really good friend is an honest friend
yeah and if you ever see someone and
they look ridiculous that person doesn't
have good friends they don't have people
that are gonna tell them they look
ridiculous yes you were the good friend
thank you that said hey Blake step it up
step it up and he s he really you think
he'd accept your uh you're you're
welcome and probably not I don't think
so no I don't think so either uh talking
about that out you're funny talking
about that offensive line you wrote I
love when you do this it means you're
very impressed with the guy who wrote
Norwell is so good oh my gosh I mean I
didn't know this was like the number one
rated guard on PFF and then he went
there we were like wow they got him too
yes what about him makes so good because
I've heard you talk about the assemblies
I've heard you talk about the Zach
Martens right you've never really dove
into Andrew Norman yeah Norwell is a
liken assembly where it's not about like
blocking you and just getting the
assignment done it's about annihilation
he does not feel good in us he's
annihilated you into the ground and I
love that about him and this is a
Patriots T line you were impressed I was
and I mean whether it was Malcom Brown
or Danny Shelton it didn't matter
and I think that's the
other thing that I took away from the
game in general you know yep New
England's in deep crap against
Jacksonville go ahead you wanted you you
wrote theme of the game if Patriots
don't blitz and rush for bortles has all
day to throw and find underneath
completion if Patriots don't blitz they
can't get within five feet of the
quarterback the Jags Oh line is stall
stonewalling stonewalling them I mean
never I mean just think about guys out
there who watch the game think about
those first few drives bortles doesn't
have anybody around him and again I'm
not taking anything away that's not a
shot on bortles I mean Tom Brady had a
lot of his career with nobody around him
but it's just impressive what they do
there and then what happened is New
England goes well damn I mean we can't
even get close to him we got to start
doing something I don't care who it is
in the NFL I mean you give somebody that
much time in a clean pocket every time
they're gonna dice you up and then New
England's arted to blitz but then
they're compromised there because they
only got one legit cover guy on their
team and that's Stephon Gilmore Eric
Rowe was they they attacked Eric ro or
Jason McCourty and neighbors a severe
mismatch all game long in that
department yeah you wrote that a number
of times
you wrote the Patriots will never beat
this team unless they have another cover
course yeah the Patriots have to make a
move and they're gonna beat the
Jacksonville Jaguars somewhere down the
road and get back to a Super Bowl and
either one has to be you add another big
weapon to your own offense and you think
okay if we get in a shootout with
Jacksonville then we can do it or they
have to make a midseason trade like they
did to get a keep to leave the year I
was there in 2012 something like that
and they're gonna continue to play this
style of defense they are not gonna beat
Jacksonville again with Arik row and
Jason McCourty having to cover Moncrief
or Dede Westbrook and you said before we
were recording that you said left go
look for a team that maybe is rebuilding
that has a corner that's making a lot of
money right the Patriots would be
willing to take that salary and the
team's rebuilding we went looked at the
list yeah one name popped out Patrick
Peterson yeah I mean that makes sense it
does I just can't see a franchise tree
the face I think I know that they have
Josh Rosen a Patrick Peterson's kind of
been the face of that franchise now
definitely on the defensive side of the
ball he's definitely yes I would say
that their gold token player right I
mean that him and David Johnson are the
two guys I think everybody would think
of and go oh those are the two best
players in their team Fitzgerald is
maybe the face of the team but he's not
the player he once was yeah it would be
something like that
to where an Arizona goes we're screwed
we're gonna go to in 14 and we need to
rebuild and blow this thing up
completely
Patrick Peterson you know it's the first
it has started the decline right and
maybe New England might go man we got
one or two years left of Brady we got a
let's see if we can make it happen that
would be the type of situation where yet
they're going to have to do that or find
something on the defensive side of the
ball that gives them an advantage but
their D line was outmatched in that
football game
middle linebacker play was an issue yeah
in the game
you wrote Hightower's not playing well
he's not existent I mean not playing
well as being nice I mean it's he's he
might as well not be there that's what
I'm just telling you it's he does he
does nothing this is Dante I know he is
not the same guy he was he's not doesn't
run as well he's not as explosive his
legs and ass don't look the same in the
pants when he used to run into guards he
would blow them back up into the hole
where he tried to blow up Norwell a few
times and normal said bring it and he
the hole opened up so those things scare
me out of the fact when you're not an
athlete and you have a Juwan Bentley
who's a bigger guy too as the game went
on they realized it and they put a land
in Roberts in the middle so--but they're
gonna have to find a new don't tinker
and figure it out but underrated quote
by you right there
what's that legs and ass don't look good
in the pants yes they don't I don't
think you need to say in the paint oh
and it was good naked or in the pants
so we're recording this we started at
3:30 on Monday I haven't gotten the
final alert yet but we got something
before we started recording which was
right the Patriots are finalizing a deal
for Josh Gordon one your initial
reaction to that I am I am surprised
that anyone's
creating for Josh Gordon right knowing
all the risk we don't even know what
happened in Cleveland it kind of sounds
like from all the stories that he came
in kind of hurt himself at a commercial
shoot and then the team was like are you
lying to us like the amount of money and
time that we've invested into you and
the [ __ ] that we've taken and you're
gonna lie that's what it sounded like
but for the Patriots what do you think
about that move well okay if it does
have right if it does happen the first
thing everybody's going is okay I mean
why would the Patriots take the risk
well first of all the Patriots aren't
afraid to take these type of risks
they've set a culture up there to where
you know guys walk in the New England
and they go damn I'm not that important
they win without me or with me so that
humbles people right off the bat and
then of course the trophies and the
rings and everything speak for
themselves so you learn as an athlete
and as a competitor right away like okay
I'm not Johnny you know Bobby big time
here they got other stars and this this
machines been rolling along so that's
why they can take the chances on the
Ochocinco let's say Albert Haynesworth
who came in there right so those type of
players because also if you don't fit in
they'll cut you in a second they don't
care like they're not gonna sit there
and go like oh I mean we made a trade
and this isn't gonna look good if we cut
them three weeks from now like what most
teams would do but they guys they'd be
worried about the PR hit the Patriots
just go nope it's time to fold them I'm
throwing my cards in the middle of table
dealer I'm folding I'm out of this hand
right they'll get rid of them and I'll
be interested to see how it goes he's a
physical freak it's definitely gonna be
a tough offense to learn for him but
they need that other guy I think that's
what happened yesterday do you think
Edelman when he comes back can be that
guy well he can be that guy but he's
only gonna be that guy in his role I
think they have to realize that it's
Jacksonville guy right you're if you've
always said the Patriots don't look at
their division they look at the
superstar looking at the Super Bowl and
they're going what are we gonna do come
out of the ANC's official official the
Patriots that's a perfect time again the
Patriots acquire troubled wide receiver
Josh Gordon from Browns for I'm gonna
say a fourth round pick
round are you kidding me they got a
first round pick I was kidding holy cow
a fifth round thing okay I'll have to
say damn I sucked in
what first round fifth round pick that
makes sense that's like nothing for
Belichick it makes sense right checks
not even good a drip no one's good at
drafting so so it's official it's
official so let's talk about it as fact
right I mean um I mean you're gonna see
a guy now that okay is a mismatched
nightmare there if he's one on one just
like Randy Moss back in the day with Tom
Brady I'm just gonna throw it up let's
see what he's got but I do think like we
just were starting the conversation
there New England it looks at it like
going to the Super Bowl what do we have
to do to get to the Super Bowl and then
we'll have two weeks a game plan for
whoever that is in the Super Bowl we'll
figure out a way to win that matchup
when it comes no matter how good the NFC
NFC team is that's their philosophy and
I just think they had to have come off
the field with Jackson and of course I
know this conversation was probably
going on before Jacksonville of course
the bills probably watched Jacksonville
in person and priests and training camp
last year in person of the AFC
Championship game and he watches film
from the first week and goes well this
team is special and they're only getting
better we're not gonna just beat them
with Gronk and Edelman like we need to
add another guy because Bowie and Ramsey
are arguably one and two in the NFL
corner
DJ Hayden's really added a nice thing
for them at the Nickelback the two
safeties are special Miles Jack's the
best middle linebacker in football so I
think that's where it all comes from
this in my opinion comes from December
8th 2013 oh I know that day when Josh
Gordon went to New England and just tore
their ass up seven catches 151 yards an
80-yard touchdown yes and he had a carry
for 34 yards I remember the game
Cleveland dominated the game and lost
and blew it lost right he had a stretch
from November 24th to that game where he
went against Pittsburgh and went 14 for
237 in a touchdown to Jacksonville for
10 for 261 and two touchdowns to New
England seven for 151 and that was when
the legend of Josh Gordon was born
and I'm sure Bill Belichick left that
game and said well yeah and you know
when you have guys like Mike Lombardi
who are the GM of the Browns at the time
and you get all the inside scoop on what
he looks like every day at practice and
you've heard about it I'm not taking any
one scoop no I don't you that you know
how the Patriots so he's flying out to
New England yep
someone that's taken your job is gonna
pick him up at the airport right they're
gonna drive him in and who does he go to
first bill Billy ball games so no one's
like hey Josh welcome to the week oh
he's gonna walk in building oh yeah take
me through he's gonna walk in the
building and there's gonna be zero
parade for him no one's gonna give a
damn he walked in the door it's Josh
yeah right like it's literally he's not
walking in black man do they even know
I'm here
like cuz they're gonna be grinding away
and they're not gonna give him
preferential treatment Bella checks
assistant bares non Jerian when you walk
into the office his office that leads to
Bella checks office is right there he's
gonna go hey Josh nice to meet you coach
wants to talk to you coach is gonna talk
to him give him probably a lay of the
land that's what I wanted right I don't
know how that combo is gonna go I don't
know why he's gonna tell him what do you
except she's gonna come in and sit down
I still have like a bunch of monitors on
as he watched and film right there Oh
without a doubt yes so Josh so he's
gonna be like no he's gonna be like he's
gonna be happy he knows what he's
capable of
yes so but do you think bill kind of
gives him a warning do you think he
tells them what do you mean he tells him
what he's expecting yeah what do you
expect of them is yeah it's gonna be
kind of the warning like like he's gonna
tell them like be here on time be here
early he's gonna give him the whole
spiel you know you know you got a you
got to turn some things around I'm here
for you to talk to if you have problems
here's bears number we'll help we'll do
our best to get you set up and make this
transition it's not gonna just be like
total dictatorship it's not like that
Bill's got better people skills and and
an ability to talk to the players and
people realize and then he's gonna kind
of just tell him that and then he's
probably gonna call Josh in or he's
gonna tell him to go see josh mcdaniels
and what's Josh coulda man josh is gonna
be like hey buddy and you know he's
gonna kind of go through and they're
gonna handle a playbook like right away
I mean it's gonna be like he thinks he's
gonna come there and like get a meal and
hey go to your room tonight and just
start diving in the playbook no they're
gonna make his butt sit down and I would
think after Josh meets him he brings him
to Chad O'Shea the wide receiver
yeah and Chad O'Shea he's gonna get the
short stick for the night cuz he's
probably left instead of doing what his
job usually is on this kind of night I'm
up to speed he's gonna have to also
divvy that up to getting him you think
they play Detroit on Sunday night I
believe do you think that he's gonna be
active depends on the hamstring rough
course right so we'll see how that is
that's not a factor yes you can get him
up to speed in that short amount of time
I do they're gonna get him on the field
and they will give him a very small
package a place he's like are they at a
point where they're gonna be like Tom
Brady's gonna get it they're gonna throw
them in there and then tom is gonna go
you're running a go yes yes go run go
and a foes run 20 yards and turn around
I'm gonna throw a back shoulder like
it's gonna be those things you're
telling me that he was they call run to
the car
turn around call some of that stuff
sometimes they call him stopper routes
and I used to love them they literally
will call a stopper route which is more
than your back shoulder go route it's a
25 yard stop route so that's where Brady
can go who stops after time under that's
right exactly exactly though that's the
point D B's go there gotta be still
going to run a go here and especially
someone like Josh Gordon relocate loses
right right I gotta go turn and yes and
then Brady sees you about 18 to 20 yards
and he goes oh he's about to stop right
there let me throw it and he leads him
to that 25 yard spot and why the other
guy was able to run full-speed to break
down a stop at 20 so you're telling me
Josh Gordon should still be on people's
fantasy teams this year I would think so
yes I know now there's the other side
yeah which is he goes there he gets the
playbook he talks to all these coaches
shouldn't be a huge adjustment I cited
me because y'all but Todd Haley his
verbage is going to be somewhat closer
to being interesting because on Hard
Knocks when Josh Gordon came
back yeah he got the playbook he said oh
I remember all this stuff none of this
is really that different oh because
let's see I wonder I wonder well you
know who else he Brad is down in
Carolina's OC right now you know Norv
Turner no no no not no where I'm missing
the guy hold on hold on oh the guy is he
the OC and it's Norv to Camp Mike Shula
no who's the quarterback coach is his
son now I'm thinking of the guy that was
in Cleveland Dwarfs II know that was in
Cleveland when Josh I got Turner hold on
a second just let me explain it Derek
Anderson was the quarterback okay back
in those days like 2012 - that I'm
totally blanking on this guy he's been
in Indianapolis the last judson ski
Kozinski Kaczynski's offense and you're
thank you in your 2013 season I think
you're talking about blew up that is
that similar verbage - because it is
from the north turner i mean yes it's
from that Parcells Chad Henne school of
offense to where it could be somewhat
somewhere sorry thanks for saving me
that's all good all right so this is
actually I'm very interested in this
Josh Gordon thing because it's a guy
going to an organization that is super
super super buttoned up and he's
anything but buttoned up yeah which it
either was Hakeem Tulane which of these
is more likely he comes in there he sees
Belichick he sees how organized it is
Tom Brady comes over puts his hand on
his shoulder and says super happy to
have you here let's go win a Super Bowl
Gronk he sees how big Gronk is and he
goes holy crap and he goes this is it or
he sees Belichick he sees the coaches
Tom Brady comes over and there's so much
going on that he is actually repelled by
it and it's too intense for him it's a
great question because that's I don't I
think it is the dynamic I think it's
it's one of the other I'm going to say
he's going to embrace it it's a magnet
you're either completely embraced by it
or you're completely repelled there
ain't no half pregnant mostly everybody
is totally embraced by it right away
okay then it's it's what they've always
thought it
what I thought it should be this success
you're getting to meet all these huge
godly figures and you're going this is
amazing yes and jack sake I can already
tell they are way more detailed here
than in Cleveland like it's gonna he's
gonna know that like pretty quickly and
he's gonna go okay so there's gonna be
the entry it's the big thing is like
after three or four weeks
are you buying and still then or is it
starting to wear on you like sure today
right and that's where like crazy boy if
you watch and touchdowns yeah it's a lot
easier to have a lot easier yes and
everybody of course is gonna be telling
what a great job be done and all those
things but yes if it gets off to a rocky
start
and now they're you know hey you got to
do this and you got to do that then yeah
that's the big question is where it goes
from there all right now I'm gonna say
this Patriots
yeah it's clicking yeah it's the
playoffs you're facing Gronk
Gordon Edelman yeah Hogan James white
Rex Burkhead and oh yeah Sony Michels
back I like the way he looked yesterday
weapons yeah I know so you think this is
gonna work out like gloriously or just
work out I mean because I feel like with
Josh Gordon he's working out it's
incredible yeah I mean I think guess if
it's working out it's going to be
incredible I'm gonna say yes it works
out I am I'm gonna say it so you're
gonna think he has a Randy Moss like mm
I think she's gonna be a force to be to
be reckoned with here in the next few
weeks
yes I don't know if I want the Patriots
to have him I mean I just yeah I don't
know what were the other teams trying to
trade the other teams that he apparently
was rumored 49ers the 49ers and the
cowboy freaky is earlier this afternoon
I wrote down that apparently in Vegas
the Eagles were the favorites and them
at even and to make room for Josh Gordon
the Patriots are now announcing they are
cutting Corey Coleman so a brown for
Brad forever a yeah Wow
yeah fifth round pick fifth round pick
uh it's still crazy to risk that yeah
but it is what it is it's not crazy for
them no no it's okay they're trying to
win a super yeah it's unbelievable the
second chances you get when you're that
town yeah
I like your burping yo man I shouldn't
have eaten food I went and I did my my
betting segment with ally for the show
which comes out Wednesdays at 8 o'clock
on YouTube that's right our betting
expert Ally is too and OH
who is he gonna take in the battle
between the Browns and the Jets on
Thursday Night Football tune in
Wednesday 8:00 o'clock other stories
we're gonna get to after Sims is film
room the roughing the passer penalty
with Clay Matthews Carson Wentz is
cleared Eli Manning and what the hell is
going on
Devante Dimas retirement Antonio Brown
vs. Odell and a few other fans stuff
quickly I want to give a shout out happy
birthday to NEMA zag Ari you are the
person give a shout-out happy birthday
didn't Eve happy birthday NEMA and then
also Austin Webber and his daughter
right listen all the time they really
like us she came up the name for his
Twitter account ATX waffle master ATX
waffle Austin Texas baby oh thanks
you're probably right yes so shout out
to Austin and his daughter ATX waffle
master what up ATX waffle master I love
waffles do you oh my
pick one honk pick one bite waffles
pancakes
french toast french tests wins every
time every time unless second is waffles
yeah
third is pancakes pancakes I just can't
trust how you're gonna make ads I only
really trust my dad and my mom and my
wife with pancakes crispy on the outside
or completely soft yeah like a little
extra oil in the pan to make them crispy
of course cuz uh yeah I don't I don't
necessarily need them crispy but I don't
want them like too doughy and growing on
the inside I used to have a theory with
my dad I think the best part about
pancakes is when you're making pancakes
and a little bit of the batter gets on
the side and they make the mini pancakes
there's like really little tiny ones
they get super crispy and you flip them
me and my dad we're like here's gonna be
our business we're only gonna make
little pancakes and we're gonna solve in
a box instead of chocolate-chip cookie
there's crushing little pancakes that's
good that's great it's great you guys
got a future you and Bruce that's all we
used to come up with ideas big things
shut up we're trying to take over the
world
okay next what we're doing though
back to the Sims film notebook yeah
Patrick
Maho home is alright so this is the
first thing that I want to say I'm
noticing a lot of people right now
loving on Patrick mahomes saying he's
great I'm seeing people taking credit
for him I believe that you were the
first person to say hey look at Patrick
mahomes everybody was talking about
Watson everybody was talking about try
Biscay everybody was talking about these
guys I'm gonna play you Sims and left go
the podcast episode 109 and we got it on
the Instagram right now I think I think
so
okay you're all about April 13 2017
nearly a month before the draft this is
what sim said about Patrick mahomes like
mahomes is gonna go in the first round I
won't even be shocked if my home's ends
up being the first quarterback take him
I think there's I think Mahone mahomes
is mahomes is rising up boards I mean I
can't tell you how many people when we
did our first Facebook live show and we
talked about my homes how many people
said I was kind of crazy to think he was
the most talented and now I have all
those same people going you know Christa
more I watched this in the homes he's
really special yeah and I want to make
no [ __ ] I mean yeah yeah I mean my homes
I think the more you watch him you just
go yeah this kid could be brett farr
aaron rodgers ben roethlisberger like it
doesn't matter what system you put him
in he's a good enough athlete and not
special the thrower that he's gonna make
the system work okay thank you thank you
thank you so I would say the last few
years you were you were all over Carson
Wentz before everybody and you were all
over Patrick for Holmes
I'd say those are two of my better ones
and I think I don't think it's the
reason we call our listeners the homies
right but you've always had a special
place for Patrick mahomes well I mean
because even before that we did our film
room right with it oh yeah but oh yeah
we have the film room we posted a
segment on it on Facebook live and that
was from like March yes so we're sitting
there going I mean look at this it's
like Big Ben yes I mean of course I
started out with the quarterbacks every
year and in my home's that year I think
I'd watched the Shawn Watson first and
sure Biscay and then I said alright let
me check this Texas Tech kid out I mean
he can't be that good
he went to Texas Tech I don't know it's
the system quarterback we hasn't really
seen someone from Tech right and I mean
I turned on the film and I was just like
wow whoa holy crap this guy is
unbelievable this is not the system he's
the team he's the offense
this isn't like we've thrown nine
hundred bubble screens in the first
quarter in our quarterback 15 for 15 for
300 yards and as a thrown ball past the
line of scrimmage it was him making one
unbelievable play after another and then
not just being careless with it I mean
he threw 41 touchdowns and ten
interceptions I think is last year there
but I took a lot of flack from my some
of my NFL friends throughout that
process really until they started to
dive into it and then I think when they
started to see the pro day and they
started to realize like whoa this is
like whoa big offseason yes and this guy
is special but I had so many ex front
office people after they saw our film
breakdown of him and all dude you're way
too high and mahomes and blah blah blah
and then like I said there a few weeks
later I started getting the text like
dude you might be on to something my
Holmes he's pretty special and I want to
make it well yeah no crap you mean you
mean the guy that's one of the most
physically gifted throwers I'm onto
something like yeah I mean you know it'd
be like watching Tyree kill and going
he's really fast but I don't think he's
that good I mean I don't know I don't
know I think also when I read the
articles now and I realized that his dad
was a major league baseball yeah so you
know that he's gonna have that
professionalism built in that's what
I've learned from you when you grow up
around it you know how to handle it
doesn't come as a surprise it's tougher
for the Josh Allen's and the sand
Arnold's that they don't there's time
right I know what it's like to be around
major leaguers you know what it's like
to grow and I read Peter Kings article
today football morning in America
talking about the the guidance that Alex
Smith gave Patrick mahomes yeah and
there's not a lot of quarterbacks that
can put aside the ego and really teach a
guy right and I think that's part of the
reason why the NFL loves Alex Smith so
much and we'll get to that a little bit
later Joe but it was such a good year
for him to sit and and what a beautiful
transition process by the Chiefs amazing
and there
there certainly is value to sitting like
we've talked about I always prefer a guy
to play I'm not gonna like change my you
know like view of that but with a guy
like Alex Smith what really happens is
it seemed like Andy Reid's
what's that to give him time to learn a
scheme like Andy Reid yes which would
you agree with me is a lot about feel
well it certainly feel there's gonna be
a lot of formation usage motions
movement all those kind of things it is
it's definitely gonna be one of the more
complicated systems but the the big
thing I think always taken from these
kind of like four instances is you
really do like when people say all we
learn to be a pro and people might be
like well what the hell does that mean
that learn to be a pro and learn it
means like what we saw in Hard Knocks
like like oh Baker Mayfield you want to
be a star quarterback well Tyrod Taylor
gets there at 5:45 every day and oh wait
so Alex he gets the game plan and then
goes into a room and he might draw up
the plays that are new so he gets it in
his mind or he writes the words down of
the play so he can spit him out it's all
the little things in the process and
what it takes to be at your best on
Sunday yes is I think what you steal I
stole of course from Brad Johnson and
what he was doing I was just saying okay
this is Brad does this on a Monday okay
that's cool I gotta start doing that too
and then when I became a starter
I started okay I'm doing that but I'm
also gonna do this too and add my own
little wrinkle to it
I'm gonna get in here early on Thursday
and Friday mornings before special teams
meeting and have this whole meeting to
myself to break down things I have my
hopes for Teddy Bridgewater go through
the roof yeah how he's with Drew Brees
sure right but there Patrick mahomes
let's talk about to do with the arm
let's do it all right so you wouldn't
watch the film of the Steelers week one
was not a fluke week two is not a fluke
this is real it's here to stay yes here
are the five things that you wrote down
about Patrick moams we're gonna do the
three things about mahomes and there are
five things about defending my home okay
so three things about my homes if it's
there mahomes is gonna hit it if it's
there like we always talk about what was
there to be had right big black portals
is finally hitting what's there to be
exactly right like you
you know we had years of Alex Smith not
taking advantage of it or I always go
back to the old Matt shop days of the
Houston Texans where people are like he
was one of the five best rated
quarterbacks in football yeah I know but
he threw four passes that were 40-yard
gains and that was great but like the
great quarterbacks put those throws on
the screws and they became 70 yard
touchdowns and people oh they settled
for a field goal
no that was there to be had and they
didn't take advantage of it mahomes
never leaves that on the on the on the
table and not to say he gets every throw
that's there
he had Sammy Watkins once but but it's
always on his mind to have the
aggressive play within reason he doesn't
overdo it just throw jump balls he's
going okay the play is designed through
this way and if there's a crack in the
armor and the defense he is going to do
his best to make you pay for no offense
to Alex Smith but he may have passed it
up yes up weird or cool I don't like the
way that looks let me be safe and
concerned but Holmes goes I'm letting it
rip oh I'm gonna I mean I'm gonna let it
rip and just wow you you wrote arm
strength doesn't matter
ha ha ha ha ha right it's just to
everybody out there who are every year
during the draft Oh Sims you only like
the quarterbacks with strong arms I know
I don't like the receivers are fast too
I mean I don't know what else to tell
you damn I like Odell and Tyree kill I'm
crazy I mean so I get sick of that talk
all the time because yeah you know why
arm strength is important because of
like he's making throws that almost
nobody in the sport can make except
certain people so that's giving Andy
Reid communists to draw more plays like
that also what people lose sight of is
he throws a short walk throw to Sammy
Watkins the balls on him so quick that
Sammy gets to get it and now he's got it
and the defenders not on him and he
makes a miss on the knee scoots up the
sideline for 20 more yards those are
little things arm strength does for you
it's not only about oh wow he could
throw it hard
it's about he makes plays that the
defense goes he can't throw this in
there whoa whoa gosh you got it how the
hell did he get that by me so he does
that he gives the offensive play call or
the confidence to
plays that he would never call or drop
for most quarterbacks and then of course
with his just great improvised improv is
an old talent I don't know how I'm
saying that prophecy imprint and
privatization of improvisational talent
I still got it wrong either way
then he can also take advantage with
that just with his great ability alone
but you know to say again arm strength
doesn't matter
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Aaron Rodgers Brett
Favre John Elway Patrick mahomes Oh Ben
Roethlisberger that's right you know he
should retire to his year the era is
over sorry that was really funny during
the game you on slack feel like oh yeah
Ben Roethlisberger sucks meanwhile I
threw for like 420 yard I mean like I
want to see all those people that put
the memes out yes last week about
trashing him they deserve to put memes
out this week that go like Ben
Roethlisberger is God or Ben
Roethlisberger is our team how about
that I mean that's what I would say to
that
make sure your defense ain't worth
talking about right now sorry I got off
topic last thing you read about my
home's mahomes is in the convo for best
in the game he is definitely one of the
most dangerous yeah there's there's
there's no denying this right now I mean
mahomes is going they play the 49ers
this week I mean Patrick Soleil
the defensive coordinator of 49ers is
going to be stressed all week he's gonna
be like damn he is dangerous and as long
as he takes care of the football
this offense is gonna be incredibly hard
to defend this is not gonna be a die out
face it's not gonna happen because he is
too gifted the offense is too creative
and he is gonna take advantage of
everything and we talked a lot about
what let's go defending the whole field
and I would say mahomes and Aaron
Rodgers make you defend the whole field
more than any other quarterback in the
sport right now and let me just say too
like man I mean it was close to being a
lot of other big-time plays I mean yeah
he's gonna throw a bomb to to Tyree kill
if he doesn't step up into the pocket so
aggressively one time he takes a sack
like if he just slid up a little bit
it's gonna be a bomb touchdown you know
I missed the Sammy Watkins things I
talked about this
down the sideline but yeah I really I
can't say enough about it and last thing
to that point is but might be best in
the NFL he's in this convo I'm not gonna
like yes like who are you gonna say
that's really better than them right now
no how are you gonna say Ryan
Fitzpatrick its Patrick's awesome
Rodgers is awesome right but like
physically the throws he's making no
it's only only Rodgers can you also
wrote what he gonna say
Tyree kill what do you want to go you
wrote Tyree kill is uncover Abul he
might be the best wide receiver in the
league seriously seriously it's it's not
like again I'm not trying to make
headlines I'm just telling you that you
cannot cover a man-to-man and even when
he's double-teamed he runs by the safety
so fast that he might as they might as
not as well not even waste a double-team
on him like I said the post over the
middle there was another play where here
in a post corner and it's gonna be a
touchdown again and he doesn't go gets
pressure and had a scramble out of the
pocket he couldn't throw it to him and
then what was the other play there was
one other play where he went to the
other side and he should have gone to
Tyreke but either way Tyree kill is in
that conversation I don't know how you
can watch yesterday and go Tyree kills
not in Antonio Browns class are you
kidding me he is if not better I mean
he's in that he's the most dangerous guy
in the sport right now with the ball in
his hands am I wrong with that
I see we just hung around so as I'm
looking at the offensive thing about
mahomes I know thinking about freezes
that you say like he makes the throws
that other people can't make right so I
think about Odell in that office yes I
mean I barely own that off he would make
everybody look good but I don't know
either way with slants and the speed
sweeps and the go routes so last week
you were willing to say Tyree kill might
be tough more now you're saying he might
be top one I mean he deserves to be in
that talk I would ever talk yeah he's
he's unstoppable and you're forgetting
about the amount of resources defenses
go what do we do ty reeks over here we
can't leave
already burns on him man to man we can't
leave you know Cameron Sutton on him and
we can't do Mike Hilton so the safety
then has to cheat better unit yeah in
terms of weapons and athletes right
Jaguars defense or chief's office I'll
still go with Jaguars D Chiefs it's
Tyreke Sammy Cal Travis Kelce Kareem
hunt the fact that I often forget about
Kareem hunter yeah and then Spencer
where yeah and I mean they got DeMarcus
Robinson catching touchdowns Chris
Conley it's awesome and their old line
has been a pleasant surprise
how were they so different than their
preseason film I think it was just they
Patrick mahomes getting a feel for
himself what he can and can't get away
with they didn't unleash the kitchen
sink they kept it pretty basic normal
West Coast stuff and then oh that was it
and go ahead defense obviously defending
Patrick Mahoney you wrote that if you
don't touch or disrupt the slot seems
you have no chance you work the Steelers
don't know what the [ __ ] to do they're
messing up assignment Hayward and to it
are losing the battle inside yeah even
on the good plays
somebody was open and they got lucky
Pitt to man was the only thing that kind
of worked kind of worked and he did a
good job recognizing to man one time and
I ran around the end because there's
nobody to cover and the the sang in the
NFL is when a team plays - man who's the
sixth wide receiver you are because
there's no one to cover you so if you
don't see anything run cuz nobody's
there to talk to you whose safety is in
the back and everybody else is playing
man-to-man five on five underneath right
and that at least made got the ball
right and he does a good job and that
did slow them down but getting back to
like you know you saw this first seam
route the rifle you know to the left
side - Chris Conley for the touchdown
then the next touchdown was the rifle to
the right side can i Travis Kelce
pittsburgh's trying to cover the seams
with their outside corners do you so you
you're impossible it's it's definitely
possible if they're not jamming the guy
that's in this
lot how can you expect a corner to go
okay we'd like you to not let the
outside receiver run a 15-yard comeback
so don't let him just have free access
we're gonna try to drop somebody
underneath you to protect the shorter
routes and then when you see the seam
route we need you to go there to steal
run over really quick right it's
impossible if nobody's jamming that guy
at the line of scrimmage what happened
so many times is they got free access
yeah and mahomes just where's the safety
I'm going opposite have fun trying to
stop this hundred and five mile-per-hour
fastball so how do you stop them I don't
have an answer for you at this point I
don't it's going to take an incredible
you're gonna have to play them through
your offense right you're gonna have to
hope to run the football take them out
of the rhythm this way your you have to
have some man-to-man corners yes which
pittsburgh doesn't have enough of them
at this point yes
teams like Jacksonville October 7th I
mean that's they're gonna be the team
where you're gonna go ok they can
physically three weeks yeah three weeks
mm-hmm in Arrowhead yeah Jaguars at
Chiefs that's gonna be awesome to be the
game of the year I mean you know and the
Chiefs their defense hey I'm still not
gonna sit here and tell you that's
anything special no they've let up like
70 points in two games but it's better
for us I mean it's amazing to watch
football Outsiders they do dvo a where
they rank it's a little bit more
mathematic than just going off of total
yards right the Chiefs have the number
one offense the number one special teams
and the 32nd ranked defense right now
that's about right it's a really fun
team to watch
I guess my follow-up question is we've
seen this with the Chiefs for a number
of years not going to start off v & O
and then flame out you don't think that
happens as you well I don't think
they're gonna continue to win every
football game I doubt they'd go five and
six and O but they're at the end of the
day I have no doubt or no fear saying
this they are so much more of a
dangerous offense and will be in just
about every game they play in to the
very end because you can never count
them out and with his ability
coupled with Andy Reid we're seeing the
first quarterback ever an Andy Reid era
that can truly take advantage of every
aspect
Andy Reid can bring to an offense
Donovan McNabb hey he was really good
and I'm not trying to take anything away
from him but it was deep balls or
screens that's all he can hit he can
never hit the 20 yard in Qatar the 20
yard out route you've got a guy now that
can do all that stuff and all the stuff
in between unbelievable yeah
alright before we get to deshaun Watson
I want to do some of the other stories
just to kind of get in before we do this
other film room the roughing the passer
penalty against Clay Matthews that
pretty much gave the Vikings a tie
because it extended the game and removed
the interception
Tony guarantee the ref said that
Matthews lifted cousins and drove them
to the ground here all preseason we
emotionally got ready to be upset about
all the helmet rules but because we were
ready for it after three weeks they
changed the rule but the entire time
this whole put like dead weight rule
what are they calling it burping it's
like body weight
it's like burping there's a sexual
really yes for the lifting and doing it
because it's a little different than the
body weight thing that is I look I think
quarterbacks are already over protected
a little bit but that was egregious it
changed it changed a win to a tie it
changed a loss to a tie it's stupid I
don't know what else to say and you know
I've heard some people like well he
called it to the letter of the law well
great I mean there's a lot of other
penalties on the field that are not
called to the letter of the law every
time so why do we always pick like these
kind of ones to go to the letter of law
I've seen people lower their crown of
their helmet like 10 times and it hasn't
been called why are we calling it to the
letter of the law this to me especially
at that time of the game it's just it's
it's over repping and to me again the
penalties in place for the egregiously
wrong like okay there is a time when the
guy does legitimately pick somebody up
and like legitimately Warren Sapp on
that running back right something like
that right where you go okay that should
not be allowed in this game like a body
slam
WWF style no Clay Matthews was running
and lowered his shoulder into a guy's
waist the exact time you hand wrapped
his arms as he was doing it and let me
just say when a guy that's 260 is
running and wraps his arms people tend
to come off the ground a little bit
unless you're tackling Russell oh [ __ ]
who's 350 pounds everybody gonna come
off the ground and to add that the call
on Rogers with Michael Kay
Kendricks was Eric Kendrick sorry yeah
they called the same thing early in the
game it's horrible I wanted there only
for when you're truly putting the player
in danger and yes again I mean I'm hope
Green Bay fans are happy they paid all
that money to see Tony Curran T steal
the show is the best player in the field
once again happy for Kirk Cousins yeah
yes thank you for going back to them yes
I mean yeah okay Kirk Cousins it's it
was very funny I got very upset to that
preseason game when I thought they were
doing this whole church of Alex Smith
about how Oh Alex Smith is better than
Kirk Cousins and though in your words
you think Washington fans were watching
that game and they watched Alex Smith
and not be able to put like any
touchdowns on the board against the
Colts and they see cousins throw four
touchdowns won an incredible throat of
feeling that touchdown throw two digs
was perfect and he did it the week
before two cousins was balling baller 22
points in the fourth quarter in Lambeau
fields would you pay him for against
Aaron Rodgers right that's exactly why
they pay him you're right okay dude we
need you to come out here and show up
against Aaron Roberts rival right and he
did that and I think people he hasn't
got the credit even today as I just like
scour the internet and all those things
nobody talks about hey Kirk Cousins
played one of the best games of the day
other than Patrick mahomes and Ryan
Fitzpatrick was probably Kirk Cousins
right exactly right and yes that should
silence all the haters in Washington DC
who were mad I don't know if they're mad
he stole RG threes job what it is but
you could see there that he's a special
thrower of the football and he is
aggressive and that is
why they came back in them football they
were out of it and then when he threw
that bomb to Diggs then it was like whoa
I know yeah there's a lot of things from
that game I mean Green Bay controlled
the fourth quarter had the ball almost
the whole fourth quarter because
Minnesota's drives were so quick it was
a to play 75-yard Drive right it was
there was then the last eighth place 75
yard driver in a minute 14 Wow so that
was of course incredibly quick they had
did one other Drive I do give
Minnesota's defense for hanging in there
and being on the field that much in the
fourth quarter you know we talked about
their lack of depth it didn't come into
play but I'll say this at the end of all
ends if Aaron Rodgers was healthy on
both legs that game would have been over
with Aaron Rodgers in the red zone
first of all Davante Adams dropped the
ball then there was also the third down
throw that was the back shoulder and you
know you know we might want to make fun
of Mike McCarthy and say how do you not
run the ball there just him no he tried
to put them away with the best player on
his team the best player in the league
and I'm never gonna fault him for that
but I do think if Rodgers has one leg or
two legs that are working those plays he
wouldn't be concerned about getting it
out so quick he would have bought more
time right and he would have danced
around and belay to the defense right
and then attacks in the line of
scrimmage somebody comes up but he
throws to that guy wide open and you go
WOW well how does he do that all the
reports were it's gonna be about four or
five weeks yeah for him to be fully
healthy yeah but if he did what he did
yesterday against most defense NFL total
stolen by 12 be okay
uh their defense is the encouraging
thing too I love it I know even though
they messed it up there at the end I
love a year and Josh yeah athletes on
the back no doubt it's nice it is josh
is better than I gave him credit for
yeah
yes self scout the actual best player in
the NFL is back carson wentz medically
cleared it's gonna start this week
against the Indianapolis Colts are you a
little bit surprised that as soon as
he's cleared he's starting or that's the
way Nick Foles was kind of I was
surprised I thought me know they would
go one more week like I'm just going
like no he's ready
do you really part of its because they
lost Mike Wallace Alshon still not there
Mac Hollins is out and the only way
they're gonna win with that kind of
receiving corps is with somebody like
Carson
it is total panic time I mean I think
that's where they've gotten I mean hey
the stats look good at the end of the
day yet you know last yesterday yeah 35
for 48 for 334 but there was really
nothing to speak of the first three
quarters no there's a lot of screens
it's a lot of crap I know Eagles fans
are like where the hell was Dallas
Goddard a guy's random people playing
right they have huge issues right now at
wide receiver yes and their defense is a
huge liability it really is what
Carson's got to put on his magic hat
again yeah he is I think so I mean your
secondary is scary right now I have not
watched that film of course yet I'm
going to be interested to watch we were
talking in the hallway though a lot of
yards to the Falcons if they didn't make
all those goal line stops it could have
been an issue no doubt and then my one
thing with the Bucs we're gonna do
Fitzpatrick a second is you know the
monster plays mm-hmm first play I go I
go you know as long as Jalen Mills
doesn't get beat deep first play 75
yards to Shaw Jackson on Jalen Mills
just no safety Hill too many times on an
island where I just want to go hey gym
shorts I respect you but who do you
think you got out here yeah who like
receivers in the NFL this day and age I
just there's some of them you just gotta
go I gotta pick my spots yes when to
play man-to-man and I think that Carson
can help out the defense because Carson
had this incredible ability last year a
third and long no doubt keeping the team
on the field exactly and if they can
keep the offense on the field and also
let the defense play with elite and
change up their way they're playing but
Carson needs to get out there extend
drives get the defense off the field
don't worry Carson you left and we're
giving it right back to you the way it
was back in the beginning it's all you
do it by yourself but the offensive
lines been great and yeah I mean but
your point about like he will help the
defense is totally correct yeah that's
the biggest thing was on third downs led
football in time of possession last year
yeah that's because of course that wants
them third down right so we'll see and
he's playing Andy not a bad defense to
start off again no what's that
uh Eli Manning our SIA 44 asked us is
Blake bortles better than Eli Manning
it's a good question he is
Blake bortles is going to be in the top
40 in the NFL for me okay I mean he's
gone up to the top 40 it's impressive
he is he's made a jump between and again
I also want to say it is the New England
Patriots who had the fourth worst pass
Stevens at football last year and they
lost their second best player on defense
to free agency so before we crown Blake
bortles as the champion of all throwing
God's okay let's just remember that the
Patriots past the events there's nothing
to write home about but yes if you gave
me and said hey one game Chris Sims
bortles or Eli Manning I'm taking
bortles Bordeaux's only so stand in
there and take shots Bordeaux's will at
least run out of the pocket and make
some plays Bordeaux's will at least
stand in there and go damn I'm gonna get
hit but I'm gonna give Donte Moncrief a
chance to go up and get this ball Eli is
collapsing you said earlier today he
looks at the pass rush then looks up and
then looks back down at the pass rush
and then he preemptively sacks himself I
there's nobody that goes down quicker in
football than Eli Manning okay and then
yeah he is he is I think out of the 32
starting quarterbacks I don't think it's
really a discussion right now he's the
least athletic out of all 32 is it I
mean am I wrong with that statement do I
need to pull up the teams there I mean
I'm gonna pull them up just so I make
sure I'm I'm correct here okay it's him
or Sam Bradford and I'm thinks
Bradford's more athletic than him I'm
giving Bradford the nod
I got what he was gonna die when Jaylon
Smith hit him well I mean his face
looked like he won like I mean he look
like his face is like what but that's
what I assume all faces are when you're
getting hit by all middle linebacker
damn I don't know I don't think I made
those faces I was like I might have been
clinching but I was like I was saying
things like [ __ ] this guy that hurt gosh
damn it if you think he like oh god no
oh gosh oh my gosh he's gonna hit me
square um it was a bad look and I'm not
gonna totally sit here and bag on him
all the way because I know the offensive
line
not good I've never seen an offensive
line that actually has the numbers to
pick up blitzes and things and they mess
ways up on passing off stun sir the
linebacker goes through this gap in the
center should take a but now the tackle
is looping around and the gorge watching
them do what they're supposed to do but
just not not doing it they can't they're
a step slower they don't get there and
then of course his inability to want to
throw the ball and get hit and I felt
bad I mean I felt like he was setting
sake 1 up to get hit by three people
every play yeah I mean yes well it was
like here you deal with it I mean that's
I don't think that's an unfair statement
here's some what well I mean I'm just
pulling them up pulling up the list very
fair here's the Giants offense the
Giants have not scored 30 points in a
game since week 17 of the 2015 season
that is a streak of 34 games the Giants
other than the 68 yard run say Quan has
66 yards on 28 carries so that one run
against Jacksonville is 51% of his yards
the big talking point right now after
every game since the Giants took a
running back over Sam darn 'old the
Giants took a running back over Josh
Alger that's the knows what the Giants
fans wanted they seized all the Giants
fans I can't stand them right now up
here in New York it says they're all
sold now they all think he likes thinks
now well now they think he stinks but
they also make excuses for him even last
week it was still another that old line
okay did you see Tom Brady yesterday
yeah he was under duress kind of hot
it's Jacksonville and Dallas is good up
run to they're really good but they were
all over kids but all we heard all
offseason with drivers all if they get a
little bitter over the line and get him
some more talent around him well damn
he's got it all start allen around him
okay as far as at the skilled positions
the o-line is a little better but I'd
like to remind everybody Justin puke
just got paid to be one of the best
guards in football he's up there Westin
Richburg was paid as one of the best
centers in football so you know yes some
of this has to go back to Eli and yeah I
mean I just think you know Eli is he's
tours
bottom of the lists as stars starting
NFL quarterbacks he is towards the
bottom of the list I mean what else is
there to say there's definitely backups
in the league that are better than Eli I
don't know everyone thinks I'm gonna
think I'm a hater cuz my dad was a
quarterback I don't give a [ __ ] about
Phil Simms or anything I'm just telling
you and keeping it real
one other quick thing about this game
from deck aft other than that Tavon
Austin play dak was 15 for 24 for 96
yards yeah offense still stinks they did
nothing in the pass game the only thing
they brought to the table last night was
the quarterback design runs which at
least kept the chains moving yeah Gabe
Ezekiel Elliott a few seams in the run
game total huff cough but still it's
just not enough no and it's hey their
defense it's something to be it's a
force this I mean you saw in week 1
Heath guy can really run he can't holy
crap and just crap how dare you yeah you
white safety exactly other big story
yesterday before you did to Sean Wallace
and all that I shouldn't be out there
anymore halftime
Vontae Davis Bills retires he released a
statement he said while I was on the
field I just didn't feel right I told
coaches I'm not feeling like myself and
it's important to walk away healthy he
literally looked at the team and said
y'all go on without me I'm going to
retire definitely haven't heard that
before
never I am torn because there's the
football side means like you're a
quitter and then there's the other side
I've always heard from people that is if
you're not going a hundred percent
you're gonna get yourself killed
right but what it took it took a game
and a half of being on the field to
realize that well maybe it takes losing
to the bills by 40 and then using to the
Chargers by 30 to go I don't know if
this is worth it like do I really want
to be on the last-place team in football
I don't know I I understand that it's
hard for me to defend it I'm trying to
empathize no I don't I mean hey I don't
want me to go real tape and do anything
I don't want them to get hurt or do
anything like that but then that's just
messed up it's kind of against the
letter of the law
in the NFL like you were there with us
all week yeah but you'll have to do the
letter of the law straight well no but
but you were there with us all week game
planning doing all of that and oh [ __ ]
got real in the first half and you don't
like the way it turned out and you're
just gonna say see you guys go out there
and finish it off I'm going home and I'm
gonna go watch the restaurant the couch
what if Shawn McDermott at halftime was
like if you don't want to be here get up
and leave and Vontae Davis like stood up
it doesn't sound like that's what how it
happened oh it's like if he I really
amateurs it to hear how it happened
because if he did like publicly say this
in the locker room where lots of players
gonna I would have a hard time thinking
that somebody wouldn't have tried to
beat his ass in the lock really yeah
like a guy like Lorenzo Alexander you
could tell how heated he was after it
like you just you know it's this is a
grown man's sport and people expect you
to be they understand the business and
all that but accountable for your
actions and yet there they are
first half it looks like a disaster and
you just decide you know what I've had
enough just that's that would piss me
off too I can't imagine that I die you
know in a way Kent I don't know why I
was thinking it helped rally the team
where we're going forward you can go
you're not quitters I don't think they
even knew it all the way like from the
way Lorenzo Alexander explained it is
like he's like you know they kind of
just told them like hey he's not gonna
be out here with us for this half and
then I bet you as the game went on the
whispers through the sidelines fourth
quarter he's out of the game he finally
hears like hey what happened to Vaughn
to him he retired man you might home
like and that's when guys you make are
you effing kidding me that's crazy yeah
that's crazy I've never seen that I've
never seen anyone quit on the team I
don't I can't think anything like that
not even retired just like pull
themselves out no that's wild yeah
Antonio Brown hmm Antonio Brown today on
Twitter someone said you're lucky you
got drafted there for all your stats and
he responded with trade me let's find
out it's a laundry list of things that
have happened
Antonio Brown the last week that for
some reason I don't hear a lot of people
talking about you know during the game
he was seen yelling at teammates and
coaches on the sideline after he was
pulled last week a reporter came out and
was I guess writing about the Steelers
and he responded on Twitter with to the
guy wait till I see you bro
we gonna see what your jaw is like and
didn't respond and then had to do an
apology and then after the game on
Sunday he left the locker room
immediately it's reminding me of
something we talked about during his
Gatorade fiasco it reminded me of when
he did a Facebook live in the the locker
room he is doing things and no one's
talking about that if Odell did these
things everybody would be talking I mean
I know you and me were on the same page
with that story right away because yeah
we've always felt like Odell has been
treated unfairly and not saying he's
been perfect but I just don't understand
I I was shocked that no talk shows this
morning or talking about everyone's
fantasy star player is threatening the
media of throwing shots at his jaw like
not even a story where I just feel like
if Cam Newton said that if an
Roethlisberger said that if Odell
Beckham jr. said that if Tom Brady said
that everyone would go this is the
problem with this guy if Dez Bryant he's
not even on a team I know like all of
them would have been held to a different
standard
why is he Antonio I do differently I I
don't know is it because he has a
million-dollar smile is it because he's
a six round pick that's why I was
confusing so so he's the under you know
he's the every man's dream guy yeah
underdogs underdog story is that what it
is is it just hey listen I he does have
a million-dollar smile he's great on
social medias this is boom but it
doesn't give you a free pass to be a
douchebag
he said left go really funny let's let
go yeah I know
I mean he's I get it he's got charisma
is there anything to the fact that he
was the only guide us to support levy on
bail could there be an issue there and
then remember
brought this up in the meeting earlier
today we don't meetings for the podcast
this is per that home and that's for the
show but I said he was also the guy were
earlier this offseason he was berating
all the local media for never being able
to just walk around Miami everyone's
writing a story about him are taking
shots at him it looked it looks like
he's getting tired of the gold the the
fishbowl yeah right it looks like he's
being he's tired of people debating him
or arguing about him it just he seems
almost fed up with it what and it's
bleeding into the field yeah I would be
tired to what why is he reading tweets
like why well what what are you what
what do you care that well it's hard for
you as an on social media user yes a lot
of us it's just kind of ingrained where
we open our phone we check Twitter we
click on that little mentions thing and
we interact with people okay like I also
think it's hard for him right because I
bet if you're the six round draft pick
that goes out there the first few years
and you're not really doing commercials
yet but you're killing it on fantasy all
of your mentions are I love you bro
you're the best bro and now he's
starting to get some of that negativity
and maybe he's just not used to seeing
I'm right yeah because I'm sure you went
in there and he's like hell yeah pop
that dopamine positive positive positive
positive and now he's just not used to
it
damn I mean just can't he go on Twitter
and not read stuff about him or go back
to the old what does he do learn go back
to the old Chris sim saying I'm sick of
unqualified people making qualifying
statements about I mean who the hell
cares what that guy's saying yeah he
doesn't really know so when you're that
big and that famous letting anybody be
able to communicate to you just does not
sound like a smart idea or something I'd
want no you know a bad look yesterday
you know it's a bad look because the way
he acted he didn't stand there in front
of the reporters after he threatened to
sink the guy's jaws and answer up and
own to that and then of course juju
Smith Schuster was the star receiver on
the field he was amazing
so all of that looks just bad in Antonio
that he's like not willing to be
accountable for his actions or not
willing to talk to the media unless he's
the star of the show at wide
apparently is also like tweeting at
former Steeler employees too and all
that's well I know I think there's
that's what they think they think the
person he was tweeting at as an ex deal
or scout or something like that I mean
I'm just gonna ask the question yeah how
much does Tomlin need to kind of get
these guys in line who kind of lets
those guys do the thing he does he
always has and they usually repay him by
being ballers and I know it's not always
been perfect yeah they're they're they
it's a soap opera they're right now I
don't think there's any denying that
they're all one in one and they got to
get things straight
you know in week one it was the office
that was the problem with turnovers and
the defense look good let's not forget
Tyrod Taylor's 15 for 40 they scored 21
points and one of those touchdown drives
was a 1 yard one play drive man their
defense played amazing that for it but
this week was a different animal coming
in town and the defense fell apart and
they thought they were gonna play an
easy team this week oh but it's the
Tampa Bay Bucs and Ryan it's bad for man
Ryan Fitzpatrick leads the league in
passing yards I don't know I know that
Jameis is the better quarterback but how
do you make the switch I saw a few
things yesterday that make me go oh crap
he's got the team right he's wearing
DeSean Jackson's clothes in the press
conference before the game there's video
of him rubbing beards with an offensive
lineman honest team like they're
touching their beards together and then
I'm seeing I'm hearing that Jameis
texted all the receivers awesome game
and you know and they all said always a
great team player but how do you turn it
over knowing that this is all gonna end
and when it does we're all gonna look at
each other and we're gonna laugh we're
gonna go oh the Ryan Fitzpatrick cycles
hilarious he comes in he fads a few big
games he convinces us that he's changed
and then he falls on his face and you
should have gone to Jameis but I just
saw a lot of things yesterday that made
me think the team likes Ryan a lot
DeSean Jackson's gotta let another man
wear his jacket Jameis couldn't even hit
two Sean Jackson last year now he's
going off under Fitzpatrick what do you
think I think it's a long time
before Jamis plays really I do I think
at this point you know when you just
break it down and look at their schedule
okay so this week like you said Monday
its Berg Monday night right I turn into
an amazing Monday and I came in at
nowhere they really did and then the
week after that
it's the Chicago Bears he's at least a
Ford of himself at this point no matter
what happens he's going to be the
starter week 6 against the Atlanta
Falcons after the bye do you think he's
earned at least 3 more weeks after if
not more maybe with this kind of
performance I mean if he goes out there
and loses the Pittsburgh Steelers and
still plays well that'll probably buy
him another 2 weeks after that Wow yeah
if he plays well against Pittsburgh you
see him starting until week 8 yes and I
don't I don't get the sense just from
the people I know around the league I
don't think Tampa likes Jameis Winston
anymore you don't think so I don't think
so no I don't know if Dirk ever liked I
don't know but I have heard that that
relationship is certainly soured maybe
I'm wrong but I know I know people in
the league and that's what I've heard
but they certainly can't think that
Fitzpatrick is the answer cuz the thing
is is you might not like him yeah and we
strongly disagree with so many of his
actions as a human mm-hmm
Jameis is 24 Fitzpatrick is no more yeah
like he's got a year or two left
I mean he's playing out of his mind
right it's all gonna be I think we're
the organization of the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers the Glazer family Jason light
Dirk cutter where they are but Jameis
Winston like I wouldn't be shocked if
their going we're wiping our hands clean
of him this year after this year we've
had enough we don't trust him all of
those things so if that's the case then
they're gonna let Fitzpatrick play until
he absolutely falls on his face and to
where they're like ok guys it's been
three weeks in a row and it's 12
interceptions and no touchdowns like
it's gonna take like crap like that you
know it's it's horrible they haven't
scored a point and he's he's throwing
the book throwing interceptions
everywhere I mean they have one of the
best mismatched teams there is to DeSean
Jackson Mike Evans OJ Howard the
for Chris Godwin yeah uh Humphrey
Humphrey I mean they're they got guys
fifty nightmares and the biggest thing
is what your Eagles deal I'm couldn't
make a mess of them second week in Iraq
and we can erode the one thing they're
absolutely thought was special right
couldn't push around that o-line they're
got a big old line police I mean two
weeks like that I gotta go meant only
two sacks in a game where he dropped
back to throw the ball thirty three
times and Fletcher Cox is one of them
which he's almost a guarantee for a sock
a sack every week I don't care if the
offensive line has five incredible myth
a lemur pet Ryan Jensen
Caleb Ben anak damar Dotson yeah I feel
like those guys were there lish high
they were they were they were it's just
it's a big group it's another year of
being together
Dirk cutters probably readjusted the way
he's taught things or called in
protections and they got to figure it
out
the other thing is my one note about why
I don't think it's sustainable other
than the fact that's Ryan Fitzpatrick
yeah six of their nine touchdowns are 34
yards or longer I they had to 75 yard
touchdowns it's not a ton of sustained
rise obviously explosive plays or
everything hard to keep going yes it is
but Ali cook asked us Ali cook if we
beat the Steelers on Monday night do you
think we are legit playoff contenders or
are we all ready with two wins over
Super Bowl tipped teams i I gotta see a
little bit more I'm not I mean it's the
first two weeks it's first two weeks
it's been an impressive offenses showing
they did not stop New Orleans one time
let's not forget goes Lee fumbled Mike
Thomas fumbled or that game would have
been to the very end we know that issue
with the Chiefs right what's that we
know that issue with the Chiefs no no
you're right I mean what are you saying
I'm saying that we think the Chiefs are
contenders oh I get you also Patrick
yeah yeah but but but no I think also
you know the other thing - yeah the
defense I guess I have that question and
you're right it's it's it's still
Fitzpatrick and it's two games yes and
yes there's weapons but I got to see I
guess we're not believing it's because
it has all the signs of something that
we're not ready to believe in but I will
apologize
anyway the Philadelphia yesterday who's
your offense has been struggling
struggling here
but I want to apologize for when we did
our season preview and when I read the
first three games of the box
I went Saints Eagle Steelers lost lost
lost yes and thus far it's been win-win
and I might pick the Bucs to be the safe
Steelers they win all right let's do two
Shaun Watson you wrote about deshaun
Watson everything is a step slow yeah
slow to run slow to pull the trigger
slow to slide in the pocket has to be
thinking of his knee yes I do I feel
like he's watching the rush more this
year than ever then I remember last year
he's taking peeks when people get close
to him he's worried about getting his
legs off the ground so he doesn't want
to get his leg caught I have to think
that's part of it but yes it's all a
little slow it's you know subtle slide
up in the pocket if you just
oh just slide up you're gonna hit the in
cut for 20 yards and he's a hare slow
stepping up and somebody grabs him and
then oh he goes to the ground a sack or
he has to escape the pocket throw it
away all you had to do was that or hey
there's a cross or open let it loose but
he takes the extra hitch to like am i
seeing it clearly you know you talked
about it and I heard you earlier this
morning
he seemed reluctant to run no question
there was a few times no question was
like third and four and I said just get
that first and take off and he just sat
there just sits there and I I have to
think the knee plays into that to a
degree do you think this is something he
grows out of this year I would think so
yes I would and I think those are things
that Billy O'Brien's gonna see and
what's the laser point on and goes can
you you need to run them Yeah right or
hey I mean make an aggressive move up
into the pocket here don't just sit here
and bounce in the same spot he's
bouncing feel the pocket move in it you
also wrote you did write the ball as
pure out of his hands I mean the ball is
pure every time it's a perfect spiral
it looks pretty every freaking throw you
are though questioning some of the play
color yeah
you said these long developing pass
plays have to go right this offensive
line can't protect Billy Oh needs to
watch some Chiefs film yes they got to
start getting people's head on a swivel
a little bit it can't just be Smash
Mouth Billy O'Brien pulling guards
I'm gonna obliterate you and then play
action and we expect to Shawn Watson to
sit back there for nine seconds too and
then make a big throw their old line is
injured it's not very good
they're keeping people in the max
protect and teams are it doesn't really
matter they're still beating the
matchups right so it doesn't matter
Rankin's is an issue at left tackle
you wrote slow and slow slow and sloppy
they got to do more on that side of the
ball though whether it's speed sweeps
the biggest thing to me that I took away
is hey I know they're gonna stay
consistent with a run Lamar Miller still
looks phenomenal but they gotta get make
sure they get their three receivers on
the field fuller
Ellington Hopkins is a pretty special
three and they can stress defenses out
and they're on the field in the first
half it was only it was always 11 per I
mean 12 personnel was one back to Ted
ends and it was either fuller and
Hopkins or it was fuller in Ellington
and I felt like it kind of played into
Tennessee's hands a few times they just
basically said okay well you know we'll
cover these two guys you'll keep your
max protection in two tight ends a block
and those type those linebackers that
were supposed to cover them we're gonna
have them add on in blitz oh okay well
your plays are taking so long to develop
and to shop suggesting and he's not
running as well and it's all just
becoming a disaster so this is one of
those teams where from a betting
perspective I'm wondering when are they
gonna flip the switch yeah and I don't
know that yet so I would be careful
about them you know cuz when they do yes
they can be dangerous
you know they're there it is yesterday
there's this is another example like you
we saw last week he throws the deep post
for an interception 50 yard bomb
intercepted by adora Jeff exactly which
is the phenomenal play if he just looks
to his left Bruce Ellington is gonna
have a wide open touchdown pass he is
beaten Butler on a go route the play I
know was designed for DeAndre Hopkins
but it was one to two and DeAndre
Hopkins was doubled from Jump Street get
off it
just because you threw it all week in
practice and coach said it was gonna be
open you got to go the other place
that's why it in practice sometimes when
coach says hey I want you to throw this
we're gonna get this open
every now and then you gotta go screw
you coach I've heard that before I need
to practice the other throw just in case
something unforeseen happens you also
did right from the Titans perspective on
their defense Harold Landry pops he does
pop man coming around the edge that Bend
we talked about that Benzema it is it's
a special Bend I mean when they get
third down passing situations and you
have rack up Oh a wreck up oh and Morgan
and Tyrell Casey inside and then Harold
Landry is the other guy on the outside
that's a pretty good for an obvious
passing situations they're gonna be a
mismatch handful and then they got three
good cover guys behind it to to slow
things down to you know who could use a
pass rusher John Gurdon can you believe
Gruden comes out and says we got to do
something to get more pressure
maybe call more blitzes it's it's like
he he doesn't realize that he cut Khalil
man are you traded Khalil man I know
it's the second game in a row where he's
like we got to get more pressure yeah
thanks
Thank You captain obvious yeah I know
it's not gonna happen I don't know what
there's not that guy on the field and
damn they better be careful about
Blitzen cuz they don't have those type
of cover guys either that'll be an issue
speaking of Raiders Raiders Nation a lot
of people were saying Sims we saw Derek
cars fastball they are right he went 29
of 32 which is insane yeah for 288 and
one touchdown but we did see that
fastball which you were asking for yes
we did and it was the what was the the
seth roberts that cost us touchdown on
the right side that was the first time
since pre hurt my back early last year
where i said there it is there's the guy
that steps into throws and rifles it
through a window it can't always be this
touch pretty flick of the ball you
there's moments of the game where you
got to drive it in there and your
receivers are gonna be more happy that
you do in anyways cuz like we talked
about my home's gonna give you more time
to react to the defender and make
something happen after the catch but yes
that was an impressive display by them
they must be sick today
19:07 I mean it's 19 to 10 the game's
gonna be over it's 4th and 1 and the
full backdrop
the ball in the flied wide open and the
game is going to be over I mean it's
going to be over what's going for the
kill Genji and it was it it was the
right call and he did it right and the
player just let him down and that gave
Denver the opportunity to go okay we're
gonna go down on a 14-play 67 yard drive
and score a touchdown to make it 1917
and they did that and then they got the
stop and then Case Keenum work some
magic there to score again and get the
game when he feels Oh
Keita was fearless that's what I love
about Case Keenum he's a baller he plays
to win yes he doesn't play to like on me
to protect my quarterback rating and
check it down just because we're in 1970
buddy's good he throw something ball
sometimes four you're like I can't
believe you're even a 10 exactly and it
hurt them a little in Week one because
it kept Seattle in but at the end of the
day he's going to find the right balance
there to where he'll go ok I I got it he
might throw an interception here or
there but for the most part you're gonna
see more like whoa that was a good throw
good place good athlete and he could
throw it remember Denver finished the
year with the fifth pick in the draft
they started last year too and Oh as
well yeah so I don't get too excited
Broncos that is your week to recap think
we touched on a lot there we did again
Wednesday night 8 p.m. the new addition
of these Sims and left coast show
Thursday morning or Thursday afternoon
really we will be having the Sims film
breakdown of a few more games that he's
gonna go through over the next few days
and I say and I want to say one more
thing you know what I want to say I
don't oh yeah ok do that ok there is a
story about I don't really know it but I
think there's a few celebrities that are
posing with what is there not posing
they're getting on this person Britney L
ok Oh Britney L if you could see it like
okay right there it's fine
it's a person holding a cheetah a
leopard leopard sorry but are you
playing God Britney L I mean whoa you're
special
you tricked a leopard a four-legged
animal and you hid in the bush and what
you do is leave some meat out for it and
then you shot it whoa yeah
to kill one of the endangered species
what the hell is wrong with the whole
world like what do you why we know these
animals are endangered and you're gonna
kill it - just what take a picture is
that what you are or what you wanted to
put his his fur on your living room for
like you're a disgusting human being and
all people that do that it is absolutely
ridiculous
I don't know they have no respect for
life at all you're a huge fan of large
cats I'm a huge fan of any animal large
cats are my favorite we know they're
becoming endangered they're down to the
thousands and we have all these idiot
rich white Americans who are bored
because they've been able to do anything
they want always and now they go I got
to go over and kill one of God's
greatest creations to justify my boring
ass rich privileged life and it bothers
me to the degree I mean I want to say so
many nasty things I don't even know
where to start play the music - Dale got
me hot I'm pissed off should have led
the show at that I wanted to I almost
wanted a shot once it is as bad as
shooting danimals all right again show
Wednesday night film break down Thursday
bedding show to anyone that took my
bachelor Friday I apologize that was bad
call them what they are oh I was a
shitbird I slacked left go yesterday oh
I like left goes [ __ ] birds and eat what
was your response I can't wait - you
have to explain bortles everybody for
six piece at home a trick says good Eve
good evening and the lef koe man there's
holla holla holla holla holla see you
guys Wednesday night to show AP up
YouTube